네 안녕하세요 오늘은 2025년도
부동산 정책과 최근의 세계적인 부동산
트렌드에 대해서 한번 좀 이야기를 해
보려고 합니다 우선 첫 번째로 부동산
정책 중에 여러분들이 유심히 봐야 될
것 중에 하나가 중도 상한 수수료
인입니다 어 저희가 중도 상한
수수료가 만약에 단기간에 대출을
받거나 큰 금액을 받았을 때 중도
상한 수수료가 되게 부담스럽거든요
중도 상한 수수료 때문에 대출을
대환을 안 하는 경우도 되게 많아요
근데이 중도 상한 수수료를 간으로
깎아 준다라고 합니다 그래서 저도
기억에 남는게 작년에 4% 후반대로
대출을 받고 있었거든요 근데 그거를
작년 말에 대환 대출하면서 3% 대로
낮췄습니다 진짜 0. 몇 프가 금액이
커질수록 부담이 확 줄어들거 그니까
금리가 높았을 때 대출 받으셨던
분들은 이번 기회에 대한 대출을
하기에는 되게 최적의 기회이지 않을까
이렇게 생각을 합니다 그리고 은행이
저도 이제 뭐 몇 번 받아봤지만 계속
이렇게 갈아타 주고 이렇게 푸시도 해
주고 해 줘야지 이제 좀 내려가더라
받은 상태로 그대로 놔두면 금 를 더
낮춰 주거나 뭔가 관리받는 느낌이 안
들긴 하는데 이렇게 옮긴다고 하면
기존 은행에서 갑자기 되게 잘해
주기도 하고 정말 좋은 조건에 대한
대출도 할 수 있기 때문에 어 저는
올해 대환 대출을 한번 알아보시면
좋을 것 같습니다 그리고 두 번째로
인구 감소 지역이나 이렇게 미분양
주택이 있는 곳들은 취득세나 양도세
이런 세제 혜택도 준다라고 합니다
아무래도 요즘에 미분양이 워낙 많다
보니까 이런 양도 소득세는 뭐
재산세는 이런 감면 혜택이 있다라고
하는데 구독자분들은 는 아시겠지만 그
세금 때문에 그렇게 인구 감소
지역이나 미분양 주택에 투자하는 거는
좀 저는 건해 드리진 않습니다 근데
이런 건 있다라고 아시면 좋을 거
같고 아마 그쪽 지역에 이제 미분양이
났던 인구 감소 지역이 있는 그런
부동산 거래량은 이것 때문에 조금
늘어나지 않을까 그렇게 예상하고
있습니다네 그리고 세 번째는 에너지
효율에 따른 이런 친환경 건물을 만들
경우에는 인센티브를 준다라고 합니다
다른 나라 자료들을 좀 보니까 이런
친환경 에너지를 좀 많이 쓰려고 하는
거 같더라고요 그에 따라서 뭐 이렇게
인센티브를 주기도 하거나 아니면 이제
매수자들이 이런 친환경 건물들을 되게
선호를 많이 한다라고 합니다 그래서
우리나라도 이런 친환경 빌딩이라는
친환경 주택이라는 이런 걸 짓게 되면
이런 여러 인센티브나 뭐 세금
혜택이라는 이런 걸 좀 주려고 하는
거 같고요 앞으로 건물주 분들이 이런
친환경을 주로 해 가지고 이런 건물을
좀 짓지 않을까 그렇게 생각을 합니다
그리고 더불어 AI 기술이 요즘 좀
많이 발달됐다아요 그래서 빌딩에 이런
AI 접목해 가지고 에너지 절감이라는
뭐 보안 강화라는 불필요하게 에너지가
나가는 거라든지 지금 건물에 뭔가
문제가 있는지 없는지 그리고 자동으로
이렇게 냉난방기 조절도 하고 정말
AI 기술이 되게 많이 발달돼서 이런
스마트한 빌딩들이 좀 많이 생겨나지
않을까 그렇게 생각을 하고 있습니다네
그리고네 번째로는 주택 임대 시장이
좀 많이 변할 거 같습니다 그래서
최근에 뭐 전세사기 때문에 이게
월세로 좀 많이 전환이 되면서 월세
비율이 되게 좀 높아질 것을 으로
예상이 돼요 이런 건물들의 임대수익
구조가 좀 많이 변경되지 않을까
이렇게 생각하고 있습니다 그리고
요즘에 워낙 그 전세 대출 때문에
어떻게 보면 전세금이 되게 높아진
거거든요 최근에 이런 전세 이런
대출도 좀 많이 줄이고 있기 때문에
앞으로 이런 월세 수요 좀 더
많아지지 않을까 그렇게 생각합니다
사실 전세 제도라는게 우리나라에만
있는 거잖아요 그래서 앞으로 전세는
더 없어지고 만약에 임대를 한다라고
하면이 월세 구조로 좀 많이 가지
않을까 이렇게 생각하고 있습니다
그리고 마지막으로 대출 심사시에 이게
이제 하반기 때부터 바뀌거든요 그래서
스트레스 DSR이라고 해 가지고 이게
3단계로 올라갑니다 금리가 올라갈
거를 대비해서 대출 받기가 어떻게
보면 더 어려워졌어요 그래서 만약에
주택을 내가 올해 사야 된다라고
하면은 올해 상반기에 꼭 매입하여야이
스트레스 DSR 3단계를 적용받는
순간 대출 금액이 좀 많이 줄어듭니다
뭐 제가 봤을 때 올해 이제 주택
건물이라는 아파트라는 이런게 좀
상반기에 거래량이 좀 더 많고
하반기에 좀 더 DSR 규제 때문에
좀 더 줄어들지 않을까 이렇게
예상하고 있습니다 그리고 세계적인 좀
부동산 트렌드를 말씀드리자면 우선
이제 상업용 부동산을 좀 말씀드리면
2023년도 이때 이제 글로벌 상업용
시장이 약 한 7.2조 달러 정도
됐습니다 근데 이게 앞으로 조금씩
조금씩 성장할 것으로 예상이 돼서
2033년에는 연평균 한 3.2%
정도 성장을 예상해서 약 한 10조
달러까지 성장할 것이라고 좀 많이
예상을 하고 있습니다 뭐 글로
글로벌적으로 상업용 부동산은 좀 계속
조금씩 조금씩 성장할 것으로 좀
예상이 되는데 근데 여기서 좀
구체적으로 봐야 될게 전체적으로 지금
오피스 시장은 어 많이 안 좋은 상황
같아요 그래서 최근에 뭐 재택 근무가
워낙 활성화되다 보니까 공실률이 좀
많이 높아졌어요 그래서 예를 들어서
미국 같은 경우에는 작년 말까지
공실률이 15.6% 있다라고 합니다
근데 이게 2026년까지
17% 한 2% 3% 더 상승할
것으로 예상이 돼요 근데 실제로 제가
가서 봤을 때는 그거보다 공실률이 더
높습니다 그리고 지금 AI 시대다
보니까 대체제는 업종이 너무 많습니다
그래서 예를 들어서 저희가 콜센터
같은 경우에도 테란로 이런데 아직
콜센터가 많긴 하는데 지금 AI
콜센터도 나왔거든요 그래서 AI
대체됐습니다 그래서 저희가 실제로
전화를 해도 AI 전화를 받는데 전혀
그런 느낌이 들지 않아요 그래서 그
정도로 되게 고도화되고 정렬해 있어요
어떻게 보면 콜센터 직원들이 일단
없어도 되고 그 공간도 없어도
되거든요 그렇게 대체제는 없 업종들이
워낙 많아지다 보니까 오피스가 굳이
필요 없어지게 됐습니다 그렇다 보니까
공실률이 되게 높아졌고 우리나라는
아직 그 콜센터가 많이 있는 경우가
많은데 AI 더
정교해지면서 아든 AI 대체될 만한
그런 업종들 그런 오피스들이 더
없어질 것으로 예상이 됩니다 어 은행
같은 경우에도 1층에 목조운데
있었잖아요 항상 은행이 눈에 잘
보이는데 지금 요즘 보시면은 그
지점도 많이 없어지고 1층에 있던게
2층으로 또 많이 올라왔거든요 그래서
그 이유가 뭐냐면 인터넷 은행이
발달된 거예요 그니까 저희가
핸드폰으로도 쉽게 은행 업무를 볼 수
있고 굳이 은행을 안 가도 되거든요
그 은행도 굳이 거기 오프라인 매장을
낼 필요도 없다 보니까 그런 수요들이
계속 줄어든 겁니다 그래서 시대가
이게 변하면서 굳이 오피스가 있을
필요가 없거든요 시대가 변화의 흐름에
따라서 오피스 공실률이 계속 높아지고
있다 이렇게 보시면 될 거 같습니다
그리고 뭔가 투자 패러다임도 좀
변화하고 있는 거 같아요 그래서 뭔가
전통적인 오피스가 아니라 뭐 데이터셋
센터 아니면 임대 주택 뭐 이런
시장들 좀 바뀌면서 이런 투자처도
많이 바뀌고 있는 거 같습니다서 뭐
우리나라를 예로 들자면
2023년도 해외 자금이 한국 상업용
부동산을 투자를 많이 했습니다 그래서
지금 워낙 환율도 좋기 때문에 외국계
업체에서 우리나라 투자하기 너무 좋은
환경이에요 그러다 보니까 투자 규모가
2023년도 3.1조 달러가
늘었습니다 근데 반면에 우리나라
업체가 해외 투자하는 건수는 좀
줄어들었어요 지금 국내 자본이
해외부동산을 투자하는 규모가 약
1조원 달러로 86% 감소했습니다
해외부동산 투자에서 손실난 경우가 좀
많았었거든요 근데 지금 해외 업체들이
우리나라 부동산을 투자하기에는 너무
좋은 시기이긴 하지만 뭐 최근의 그런
뭐 개업용 이라든지 이런 것 때문에
되게 조심히 볼 거 같아요 앞으로
조금 회복되는데 시간이 좀 걸릴 거
같긴 하는데 지금 외국 업체들이
우리나라의 투자하기에는 매우 좋은
환경이다 환율이 너무 높아서
정상적으로 저희 저희가 뭐
1,200원대 1300원대 보다는
거의 한 2 30% 더 싸게 살 수
있는 기회거든여
했는데 환경이나 사회 그리고 지배
구조를 고려한 투자 전략이 되게
중요합니다 앞서 설명드렸던 것처럼
신환경 소재로 만약에 뭐 건물을 만들
경우에는 그에 대한 뭐 인센티브가
증가하고 지금 글로벌 적으로도 그런
친환경 부동산의 수요가 많다라고
합니다 그런 수요들이 앞으로 많이
늘어날 것으로 예상이 되고 이건 전
세계 적인 트렌드인 거 같습니다
그래서 지금 영상을 보시는 건축주분이
계신다면 이런 항목들은 좀 세부적으로
파악을 하신 다음에 어떻게 하면
인센티브를 받고 세금적인 감면을 받을
수가 있고 물론 이제 우리나라는 아직
구체적으로 뭔가 접목되거나 그런 거는
없기는 하지만 올해 정책 중에 그런
내용들이 있긴 하거든요 이런 내용들을
한번 상세하게 보셔 가지고 앞으로
세계적인 트렌드가 이런 부동산의
수요가 많다 보니까 이거를 감안해서
나중에 뭐 건물을 뭐 신축하거나
리모델링 하시면 좋을 거 같습니다네
그리고 주거 시장을 좀 말씀드리면
세계의 약 한 56% 다 도시에 살고
있다라고 합니다 그래 우리나라도
서울이나 거의 수도권에 다 살고
있잖아요 세계적으로도 다 대부분은 다
주요 도시 그러니까 이제 거의 수도
근처에 살고 있다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 그래서 뭐 모나코라는
홍콩이라는 뭐 런던이라는 뉴욕이라는
이런 세계적으로 유명한 도시들은
부동산 가격이 되게 비쌉니다 근데
그거와 반해서 우리 한국은 아시아에선
좀 높 높은 편이긴 하지만 그런
도시들 대비해서는 그래도 그렇게 높은
편은 아니라고 보시면 될 거 같고
근데 GDP 대비해서는 거의 세 배
정도 됩니다 그래서 지금 서울 같은
경우에도 가격이 계속 좀 많이 오르고
있잖아요 GDP 대비했을 때는 한 세
배 정도 되는데 그 세 배가 다른
나라와 비교해서는 그래도 높은 편에
속해요 그 이유는 뭐냐면 서울은
세계적인 도시와 대비해서 밀도가 되게
높아요 세계적으로 보면 되게 작은
도시인데 사람들이 엄청 많이 살고
있는 거예요 거의 천만 명이 살고
있으니까 그 정도로 인구 밀도가 매우
높고 그리고 이제 급격하게 많이 오른
주택 가격 그리고 이제 제한된 공급
때문에 이런 부동산 가격이 계속
오르지 않나네 이렇게 생각을 합니다
그리고 사실 뉴욕 우리가 가봤지만
공중권 있고 그리고 개발을 확실히
풀어줄 만한 데는 확실히 풀어주고 막
그런 부분이 있어서 뭐 공급이 아직
부족하긴 하지만 체계적으로 잘 돼
있거든요 근데 우리나라는 너무
규제들이 너무 많아요 이런 공급을
늘릴 수 있는게 쉽지 않습니다 그리고
어디를 묶어서 개발하 기도 쉽지
않아요 워낙 이해관계인들이 많다
보니까데 시간도 오래 걸리고 비용도
많이 들고 이런 규제 상황들 때문에도
더 이런 부동상 가격이 오르는게
아닌가네 이렇게 생각하고 있습니다네
그리고 마지막으로 우리나라는 지금
초고령 화사에 접어들었어요 65세
이상 인구가 약 한 20% 정도
됐습니다 그렇게 됐을 때 보통
초고령화 사회라고 하는데 그러다
보니까 앞으로 부동산 변화도 좀 많이
달라질 거 같아요 그래서 저희 뭐
앞으로 뭐 10년 뒤 모습이라고 하는
일본을 보자면 일본은 이제 65세
이상의 인구가 30% 근데 이제
우리나라가 30% 되는게 정확히 거의
한 10년 뒤든 일본 지금 도쿄 같은
경우에도 가서 보면은 거기도 부동산이
오르는데만 오릅니다 수도에서 좀만
멀어져도 부동산 가격이 진짜 천차 만
별이든 제가 봤을 때는 앞으로 이런
시니어 관련된 사업 그리고 이제
시니어 관련된 부동산 상품들도 좀
많이 나올 것으로 예상이 됩니다 좀
이런 일본을 좀 많이 봐야 될 거
같아요 일본이 지금 어떻게 되어 있고
지금 어떤 상품이 발달되어 있고 지금
사람들의 어떤 수요가 많아졌는지 좀
일본 을 좀 유심히 사례로 보시면은
좋을 것 같습니다네 그래서 오늘 좀
전체적으로 설명드렸습니다 그래서
우리나라뿐만 아니라 뭐 세계적으로도
좀 설명을 드렸고 좀 여러 나라 중에
좀 일본을 좀 유심히 봐야 되고 어
초고령화 사회에 접어들다 보니까
앞으로 부동산도 그 초고령화 사회에
맞게 좀 많이 변화될 거 같습니다
그래서 이런 부분을 좀 유심히
보셨다가 나중에 부동산 투자하시는
도움이 되셨으면 좋겠습니다 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하겠습니다 빌딩은
역시
빌사남 k
[음악]